[Applause]
Dubai nearly 7 000 miles from South
Africa's seat of power and home to a man
who's been pulled into its politics
we've been invited to the home of haza
Mustafa the sunni's businessman who has
found himself at the heart of what is
now known as Farmgate the political
Scandal that could see South Africa's
president face impeachment proceedings
an independent inquiry recently found
that Cyril ramaphosa may have violated
the Constitution after a political rival
filed charges of corruption and money
laundering the allegations exposed a
secret theft of a large stash of foreign
currency from his game farm nearly three
years ago ramaphosa says this man is the
source of the cash stashed in the couch
has him confirmed that he paid 580
000 in cash to buy 20 Buffalo from
palapala Farm it says because of covid
they were never exported and now he and
his South African wife are making
headlines I'm shocked for sure why they
put it there you know
uh why didn't they send it to the bank
it's also a Christian is there
on the 23rd of December 2019 hazim land
in Johannesburg with six hundred
thousand dollars in cash
two days later on Christmas day he
drives to palapala farm he hands over
580
000 for 20 Buffalo then leave South
Africa the next day as ramaposa arrives
at the farm ramaphosa tells staff to
deposit the cash but after he leaves
it's transferred from the safe to the
cushions of a couch
according to ramaphosa this money was
stolen so the money is no longer there
you know once I gave it I gave the money
the ownership of the money has been
transferred from me to him
and the receipt is my my my evidence for
the for the payment it's by law or by
Logic sense none of this was public
until June
at this point were you aware that the
president was involved in the Buffalo
sale I'm from when I hear the news yeah
this is the first time to really really
know that he is his owner because if you
saw the structure if for the far it's uh
belonged to trustee
and this trustee I think belonged to his
family
this is the copy of the Declaration
now cooperating with the South African
authorities and says he's handed over
his evidence
he shows us the documents but won't let
us film them
so this is a declaration form hazim
Mustafa Muhammad Ibrahim or Tambo
international
arrivals a it's got your date of birth
it's got the time 23rd of December 2019.
you arrived at 507 pm and you declared
600 000 U.S dollars
the Farmgate Scandal has fractured
ramaphosa's anti-corruption platform and
raises questions around his credibility
at a critical moment for his party
South Africa's Parliament will soon
decide whether ramaphosa will face
impeachment proceedings and is for the
man who bought the Buffalo he's ready to
take the stand anything to help the
justice and to to show the the truths
I'm here I have nothing to hide
back in the safe and not in the couch
Sky News Dubai